[संगीत]
हेलो
कर दिन और वेट करते हैं चालू करेंगे
गुड इवनिंग
और थोड़े नए-नए देने से ग रहे हैं
ओके तो हेलो गैस मैं हूं
सिक्योरिटी की तरफ से आज हमारा पाइथन का
डेट फिक्स है जो हमारे कैप्सूल कोड चल रहा
है उसका डी लास्ट दे है कल अपन प्रोजेक्ट
भी देखेंगे
तो प्रोजेक्ट भी सोच कर रखना है टेलीग्राम
के अंदर जरूर बताना प्रोजेक्ट का की आपको
किस टाइप का है मैंने कल इस बड़े में
थोड़ी सी बात कारी थी आज भी थोड़ी सी और
अपन बात करेंगे
थोड़ा सा इंटरेस्टिंग सा हो वो और आज का
थोड़ा सा चीजें इंपॉर्टेंट भी है की ये
बहुत कम आता है बहुत अगर जिन लोगों को इस
चीज के बड़े में नहीं पता लोग रहते हैं उन
लोगों को इस चीज में बहुत दिक्कत आई है तो
वो चीज आज अपन देखेंगे की कैसे उसको
रिजॉल्व करें और सब कुछ
तो ठीक है फिर आगे बढ़ते हैं
तो आज अपन पढ़ेंगे अपना फंक्शंस के बड़े
में
फंक्शन क्या होता है फंक्शन एक सिंपल सा
चीज है एक ब्लॉक ऑफ कोड राहत है देखो
पॉसिबल है प्रोग्राम के अंदर अपुन की एक
ब्लॉक ऑफ कोड है जो अपुन को बार-बार रन
करना होता है तो उसके लिए अपन हर बार उसे
कोड को कॉपी पेस्ट नहीं कर सकते की यार
मां लो मैंने बैंकिंग का सिस्टम बनाया और
उसके अंदर अमाउंट जब डेबिट हो रहा है तो
भी अपन का अकाउंट अपडेट करना है क्रिएट हो
रहा है तो भी उनका अकाउंट अपडेट करना है
तो अकाउंट अपडेट वाला जो चीज है उसके लिए
जो भी अपने पर्सनल वगैरा हो रहा है अपन
बैक हैंड में कल कर रहे हैं और अपन मतलब
सर अपना
चेंज वगैरा कर रहे हैं तो उसे चीज को अपन
बार-बार तो नहीं लिख सकते ना तो एक जगह
लिख के छोड़ देते हैं अपन फिर जाके ना इस
चीज को वन लाइन में अपन बुलेट हैं यहां
भाई तो ये ये मैंने कल कर दिया वो जगह पर
जाएगा और वापस जाएंगे
तो वो सीन अपना राहत है
अपना फंक्शंस के साथ में ये फंक्शन है
जिसको अपन को बार-बार लिखने की जरूर नहीं
पड़ती एक बार कोड को लिख दो फिर एक लाइन
लिखने पे वो पूरा ब्लॉक को अपना
एग्जीक्यूट हो जाता है और ये एक ब्रोकर
कोड एक रिटर्न भी करता है
तो उसे चीज वगैरा के बड़े में रिटर्न क्या
होता है रिटर्न टाइप
पैरामीटर क्या होते हैं वह सीन देखेंगे तो
जो लोग पहले से सी सी प्लस पर जावा वगैरा
पड़े हुए हैं जैसे पछता है समय देखा था
बहुत ने पढ़ रखें थे
मीटर वगैरा वगैरा देता हूं की पहले
अरगुमेंट्स वगैरा क्या होता है आर्गुमेंट
नॉर्मल सा चीज होता है जैसे
अपन देवी भी कोई फंक्शन में कल करिए और
पेरेंट्स के अंदर जो चीज अपन लिखने हैं
उसको अपन अरगुमेंट्स कहते हैं अपन
आर्गुमेंट कितने भी पास कर सकते हैं वैसे
कॉमर्स सेपरेट करके
और पैरामीटर डिफरेंस
होता है उसे डेफिनेशन के वक्त में जो अपन
वहां पर वेरिएबल डिफाइन करते हैं वो अपने
पैरामीटर वगैरा
फंक्शन डेफिनेशन
हां सब देखो यह जो भी टर्म्स होती ना
प्रोग्रामिंग की टर्म्स अपना हर
प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज के अंदर अधिकतर से
ही होता है मतलब 99% से ही होता है नीचे
हो सकता है बाकी टर्म्स तो से ही होती है
कैप्सूल के अंदर क्लासेस वगैरा हो गई अपना
फंक्शंस वगैरा हो गया इन सबका चीज सब
चीजों का सब कुछ से ही राहत है तो बस अंतर
हर पकड़ में बताओ ना
99% से ही होती है बस जो उनका अंतर होता
है वो अंतर बस उनके सिंटेक्स के अंदर आता
है बाकी लॉजिक हो ही लगता है एग्जीक्यूशन
में थोड़ा ऊपर नीचे हो सकता है कुछ
लैंग्वेज होती है कुछ वैसे एग्जीक्यूट
होती है लेकिन लॉजिक सब में से लगता है बस
लोरी से मतलब एजुकेशन का तरीका थोड़ा सा
अलग हो सकता है
अपना डॉक्यूमेंट में आज अपना डेट 6
कल किसी ने कहा था की थोड़ा राइटिंग
अच्छा लगता है
फिर इसके अंदर
वर्ल्ड वाइड का ऑप्शन नहीं आता है वर्डवेब
का मतलब जैसे ये लाइन अगर यहां पर खत्म हो
जाति है जैसे
यह लाइन यहां पर खत्म होने के बाद में
क्या इसके आगे हो जाते र जाते रहेगा
तो वह सीन यह आइडल का ऑप्शन ही नहीं दे
रखा है इसलिए लोग आइडल इस्तेमाल नहीं करते
हैं मेली वो लोग अपना इस्तेमाल यह वीएफ
कोड वगैरा ही कहते हैं बट अपन आइडल किसके
लिए भी कम कर रहे हैं क्योंकि अपन को
थोड़े बेसिक सीखने के कुछ शब्द ऐसे होते
हैं पाइथन में जब अपन को याद रखना ही
चाहिए
राइटिंग फाइल क्या होता है भाई बताओ एक
बार ये स्क्रिप्ट वाला पेज है इसको
अगर इसकी ये बात करो तो यहां ऑप्शंस बताना
यहां पे कॉन्फ़िगर आइडियल का ऑप्शन ए
जाएगा वहां पर हो जाएगा अभी जस्ट मैंने
करके दिखाए था
तो चेक करके इस्तेमाल
करेंगे ताकि अपन कल प्रोजेक्ट
को उसे करें नहीं तो अगर आज टाइम नहीं रहा
तो फिर अपन कल ही स्कोर सेट अप करके वहीं
पर ही करेंगे प्लीज आपको प्रोजेक्ट चाहिए
वो टेलीग्राम का हमारे चैनल पर आपका बता
दो की आपको किस टाइप के प्रोजेक्ट चाहिए
जो अच्छा लगेगा पिक जरूर किया जाएगा उसे
तरीके से पाल भी वहां पे रन करेंगे बस
थोड़ा सा एक्टिव वहां पर दिखाओ और साथ जो
भी लिंक वगैरा इस वीडियो को डिस्क्रिप्शन
में आपको दिखेगा या हर वीडियो को
डिस्क्रिप्शन में आपको लिंक वगैरा जाते
हैं बट फिर भी एक भाई का रिक्वेस्ट था की
इसको इंक्रीज करने का तो मैंने इंक्रीज कर
दिया है
ठीक है
तो अब देखो जैसे मां लो आपको ऐसा सिस्टम
आए तो उसको वेलकम का मैसेज आया तो अब उसके
बाद क्या रहेगा
कर बार वेलकम प्रिंट करो यूजर कितने भी
आएंगे जितनी बार भी गुर्जर रहा है अपुन के
वेलकम चाहिए तो उसके लिए अपने करेंगे यहां
पे एक फंक्शन बना देंगे देश अपना इसको
डेफिनेशन बोलते हैं डीएफ मतलब डेफिनेशन
इससे अपना फंक्शन बंता है ठीक है ना अब
फंक्शन
का नाम देना पड़ता है ये जैसे वेलकम में
इसका नाम दे देता हूं
ठीक है
सॉरी सबको मेरे को भी क्लास रोकना पड़ा था
क्योंकि कल ए गया था मेरे घर से मैं बाहर
राहत हूं तो घर वालों को कल करना था जरूरी
सा जाता है नहीं तो फिर उनको लगता है की
कहां गया क्या हो गया टेंशन हो जाति है उन
लोग तो इसलिए उनका फोन इग्नोर किया जा
सकता है किसी भी कंडीशन में
हां तो मैंने यहां पर फंक्शन बनाया अब मैं
फंक्शन के अंदर एकदम प्रिंट
वेलकम यूजर
लिख दिया
चलो मैं इसको रन करता हूं
यहां पर क्रिकेट हो जा रहे थे लेकिन
फंक्शन की खासियत यह होती है की एप्पल जो
फंक्शन लिखने हैं
वह तब तक फंक्शन नहीं चलेगा जब तक अपन
फंक्शन को कल ना करें
ठीक है
यह अपने जिंदगी का वही दोस्त है दोस्तों
अपन कल करेंगे तो ही वह कम करता है अपने
बेस्ट फ्रेंड की तरह नहीं है की उसको वो
कभी भी मुंह उठाकर ए जाए ऐसा फंक्शन नहीं
होता है ठीक है
फंक्शन कल आपको करना ही पड़ेगा
यहां पर सीधा सा मेरे को यह ऐसे
ओनली एक वेलकम लिखा उससे ये पूरा कम हो
गया अब मैं चाहे तो उसको कितनी बार रिपीट
कर सकता हूं यहां पे अगर मैं ये लूप में
लगा के फंक्शन को रन करूंगा तो भी अपना ही
कम करेगा तो इस इस वाले पार्ट को जब हम
कहते हैं उसको बोलते हैं फंक्शन डेफिनेशन
कॉलिंग
ठीक है
तो अपन फंक्शन के साथ में अपन अरगुमेंट्स
वगैरा भेजेंगे
ठीक है तो देखो
ना दूंगा नाम के नाम से ठीक है
कोमा न्यूज़
पैरामीटर यहां पे दाल रखा है और में
फंक्शन को बिना किसी आर्गुमेंट के यहां पे
पास करता हूं
तो एरर दिखाएगा मुझे
वेलकम फंक्शन
[संगीत]
पैरामीटर
एक पैरामीटर जिसका नाम है नाम
के अंदर
प्रिंट कर रहे हैं तो वेलकम के साथ में
अपना पारा अगर अपन ये
वेरिएबल का नाम लिखेंगे तो जो वेरिएबल में
स्टोर है मीत तो वो यहां पर ए जाएगा
ठीक है
जैसे यहां पे मैं लिखना हूं
लास्ट नाम तो
उसने
तो यहां मैं किसी का भी आप मैसेज
चलो
ठीक है अभी चाचा वाले के अंदर
यह पीछे है तो पीछे
डिफाइन करना पड़ेगा
[संगीत]
नाम से मैं वेरिएबल बनाता हूं आपको
ठीक है
यहां पर डाला तो मैं इस फंक्शन में अभी
लिस्ट पास करूंगा
प्रिंट कर के भी देख सकता हूं लेकिन मेरे
को टाइम दिखाना है की देखो लिस्ट गया है
प्लीज इसका टाइप है तो अभी मैं क्या कर
सकता हूं इसके अंदर
इसको मैं ऐसे भी लिख सकता हूं की
और
यूजर ल
यूजर्स
वेलकम
सर
बात करता हूं
यह तो अपना लिस्ट है इस लिस्ट को मैं अब
यहां पर
जरूरी नहीं है मेरे पास करना है यहां पर
देखो इस वाले वेरिएबल का नाम कुछ भी हो
सकता है
वेरिएबल का नाम है जो आगे लिखा है वह आगे
वाले वेरिएबल को एक फैन होगा या फिर आपको
स्पेसिफिकेशन
ठीक है
बट अपुन को ऐसा चाहिए की जो अपना यूजर है
ना बांदा जो अपना है वो बांदा कितने भी
अरगुमेंट्स पास करें
क्या
करना पड़ता है ना की मां लो की
सब लोग का जो नाम है
ठीक है अब यहां पर क्या लिखना पड़ेगा ना
मुझे इसको बोलते हैं अपन
बताने के लिए अपन को आगे स्टार्ट लिखना
पड़ेगा
इससे क्या होगा ना ये जितना चाहे उतना
आर्गुमेंट यहां पर लेना चालू कर देगा
चालू कर देगा ठीक है अब अपन देखो जैसे अपन
इसके अंदर थोड़े से पास कर लेते हैं जितने
भी नाम है यहां पर वो नाम अपन सारे के
सारे पास कर देते हैं
ठीक है
क्योंकि इस वीडियो को वैसे भी चेंज नहीं
कर सकते हैं जो अभी यहां पर ए गया है
तो उसका टाइप चेंज भी कर सकते हैं
दूसरा नाम डाला है दूसरा नाम है अगर अपन
को प्रिंट करना है ये तप है तो टप्पल है
तो अपन इसके अंदर सिंपल सा
इंडेक्सिंग करके ही अपन ये फर्स्ट वाला ये
जो पसंद नेक्स्ट पर जो लिखा हुआ है लक्षण
वो ही प्रिंट हो जाएगा
तो ग जाता है
यहां पर तो मैं कल लिखूंगा चप्पल
वगैरा है यह सब कुछ मैं पहले बता चुका हूं
क्या-क्या होता है क्या क्या नहीं होता है
तो जिन लोगों की ये वाली फर्स्ट क्लास है
वो पहले वाले क्लासेस जाके देखो और मैं
तुमको पता लगेगा ट्रबल चीज क्या होती है
लूप्स क्या होते हैं चप्पल्स क्या होते
हैं
लिस्ट क्या होती है तो अगर ये वाला लेक्चर
उनको इतना समझ में नहीं आएगा क्योंकि जिन
लोगों ने पहले
ऊपर से जान वाला है
तो मैं यही सब को क्या हुआ की पहले पुराने
वाले लेक्चरर्स देखने का उसके बाद ही इस
दे सिक्स पर आने का विदेशी से दिन बढ़ते
रहेंगे वैसे-वैसे चीज परिसर होती रहेगी
ठीक है
अभी लूप चलेगा
जितनी भी चीज पड़ी होगी वो सर एक-एक करके
ट्रेड होगा और वो यूजर में जाके से होगा
एक-एक करके यूजर हो जाएगा से होगा और वो
ओपन यहां पे प्रिंट करवा रहा है
तो देखो वेलकम सर
अब इसके अंदर एक और राहत है अपना
बॉक्स करके राहत है
ना उसमें क्या होता है अपना उसके अंदर अपन
क्या करते हैं
मैं वो वेरिएबल का सकते हो उसको अपन एक
डिज्नी टाइप बन जाता है
उसको प्रैक्टिकल करके दिखता हूं तो आपको
ढंग से समझ में आएगा
[संगीत]
फ्री बताएं
और अपुन फिर जैसा चाहे वही हो जाएगा फ्रॉम
तपन यहां पर दिखा सकते हैं जैसे काफी अलग
ए गया है
अपना यूजर
कमांड
रिवाइज करवा रहा हूं इसलिए मैंने आज कोई
स्टार्टिंग नहीं लिया है
जो लोग पहले से नहीं पढ़ के आए हैं
क्योंकि सब कुछ पहले कर दिया गया है बस
इसको ओपन में थोड़ा सा इंटरएक्टिव वे में
बैंड कर रहे हैं
यह फंक्शन वाला चीज ए गया बहुत कम आने
वाला है गैस मैं 11थ में था वो तो बिल्कुल
नहीं पढ़ाएगा तो उसके बड़े में तो मेरे को
बहुत दिक्कत आया था मैंने बनाया था उसके
अंदर
आपने बताया क्यों नहीं किसके बड़े में तो
देखो अगर अपन ने देख लिया की यार अपन देखो
जैसे मां लो की मैंने यहां पर डाला की यार
डीटेल्स नाम दाल अपना
तो देखो
तो मैं 3 सॉरी
तुम देख लो तुम्हारे साथ से जो तुम्हारा
है वो तुम देख लो मुझे नहीं देने का है
ठीक है ना तो उसे कैसे में क्या है ना अपन
एक चीज को है ना मदद कितनी भी चीजों को
ओपन करना है भाई डिफॉल्ट कर सकते हैं
जैसे मैं चाहता हूं स्टेट अपन डिफॉल्ट में
ले लिया अगर कोई अपना स्ट्रेट ना डालें तो
यहां पे
राजस्थान ले ले
ठीक है तो उसे कैसे में क्या होगा ना मैं
यहां पर डालूंगा और अभी मैं यहां पर स्टेट
नहीं लिखना हूं और ये भी स्टेटस
मिक्सिंग
अगर तुम डालोगे तो चीनी हो जाएगा करके
देखते ही देखो
चेंज करके महाराष्ट्र कर दो
चेंज हो रहा है नहीं दाल रहा हूं तो जो
डिफॉल्ट अपन ने डाला है वो यहां पर ए रहा
है ये अपना होता है
जैसे बताइए वाले पैरामीटर होते हैं
ये वाला आर्गुमेंट डिफॉल्ट नहीं होती अपन
को पास करने पढ़ते हैं
तो यह अपना राहत है
यहां पर चाट में लिख डॉग
जल्दी यहां पर
किलोमीटर बनाते हैं
मेरा टेस्ट करने को कितना बजे नॉलेज है
तो सबसे पहले यह चीज डिफाइन कर लेते हैं
की यूजर क्या करेगा
2 अप्रैल
पूछेंगे की भाई तुमको क्या करना है की
एडिशन करना है या सब्सट्रैक्शन करना है या
फिर डिवाइड करना है की मल्टीप्लाई करना है
वो अपन ये दोस्तों पूछेंगे तो इसके बाद
में अपना पीछे ऐसा रन होगा की एक दो
पैरामीटर अपन पास करेंगे और उसके अलग-अलग
फंक्शंस वगैरा बनाएंगे
तो सबसे पहले अपन
नंबर
उसके बाद में अपन न्यूज़ से पूछेंगे की
भाई तुमको क्या करवाने का है
नंबर भी ले सकते हैं
मैंने बताई थी अगर आज का वैल्यू अपना राहत
है एडिशन
रिमाइंडर
अब मैं
अब यह जो फंक्शंस चीज ना यह जो भी फंक्शन
है यह फंक्शन कुछ चीज रिटर्न करनी चाहती
है
फंक्शन एक एडिशन रिटर्न करना चाहिए
डिवाइड करो
मल्टीप्लाई करो
जैसे कोई फंक्शन बनाते हैं तो उसके अंदर
एक वाइड राहत है व्हाइट फंक्शन राहत है इन
फंक्शन देता है तो इनफॉरमेशन मतलब कुछ
वालुज रिटर्न करता है वो एड कुछ रिटर्न
नहीं करता जीरो रिटर्न करता है ऐसा पाइथन
में बिल्कुल नहीं होता आपको रिटर्न करना
चाहे तो करो नहीं तो नहीं करो वो पाइथन
बाद में पीछे देख लेट है तो करने का क्या
है ठीक है जरूरी नहीं होता है
वो रिटर्न टाइप लिखा जरूरी हो जाता है
जैसे अगर आप लास्ट ओवर के साथ में कम
करेंगे
तो वहां पर कभी-कभी रिटर्न टाइप देना
जरूरी हो जाता है
लेकिन मुझे आपको रिटर्न देने का है इस
टाइम दे रहा हूं तो अगर कोई भी अगर कोई
फंक्शन रिटर्न करता है तो आपको वेरिएबल
में से करना पड़ता है तो मैं यहां पे
लेट हूं
एरर
रिजल्ट
लेकिन पट लिया
स्ट्रिंग वाला ठीक है
भाई मुझे यहां पर एडिशन करने का है तो
एडिशन करने के बाद
कंडीशन लगे मैंने कहा भाई आज पूछो मतलब जो
ये आज जो वेरिएबल है अगर इसके अंदर प्लस
स्टोर होता है
रिटर्न रिजल्ट
शुरू हो जाएगा अगर अपन ने कुछ रिटर्न नहीं
जा के कुछ स्टोर नहीं होगा इस चीज का
थोड़ा खास ध्यान रखना
ठीक है
लिखने जाएगा
कल करेगा
से करेगा
कल करेगा कल करेगा
कुछ भी ऐसे लिख देता हूं
और यह रिजल्ट
अपना कम कैसे करता है
ठीक है अब इसके साथ में अवेलेबल है
एक कम करता हूं
ऐसे इनपुट डालते हैं
अगर पहचान
बना रहे हैं
लाइब्रेरी वगैरा उनका इस्तेमाल करके अपन
गो भी इसका बना सकते हैं तो उसे कैसे में
अपन
लिखने ही वहां पर हो जाएगा
आपका एरर जो है वो यूजर देखें
मतलब प्रोटेक्शन में कम कर रहे हो और उसके
वक्त में आपका प्रोग्राम यहां पर एकदम
टर्मिनेट से हो जाए तो बिल्कुल भी किसी को
अच्छा नहीं लगेगा
[हंसी]
ठीक है
ना बेटा
[हंसी]
ठीक है ये तो देखो इस कैसे में हुआ जब अपन
को यहां पर कोई भी ए रहा है तो इस अभी इस
इस सिनेरियो में क्या रहेगा ना इस जगह पे
कोई भी एरर ए जाएगा ना कोई भी मतलब कुछ भी
ए जाएगा नहीं इस जगह पर तो वो इस वाले
ब्लॉक का एग्जीक्यूट करेगा सबसे पहले क्या
होता है ना प्रोग्राम जाएगा भाई साहब
देखेगा भी ट्रब्लॉक के अंदर क्या लिखा है
तो पहले वो ट्राई करो जाकर रीड करेगा यहां
पर अगर मां लो रीड करते वक्त मैं यहां पर
अगर कुछ कंपिल करते वक्त में या और कंपल
पुरी करता है इंटरनेट कर रहे हो वक्त में
कुछ भी यहां पर अलग आता है तो वो सीधा
इसको छोड़ कर या एक्सेप्ट वाले ब्लॉक में
जाकर जो एक्सेप्शन ब्लॉक में जो लिखा हुआ
राहत है वो जाके एग्जीक्यूट कर देगा
आपको कोड में वो एग्जीक्यूट करेगा एग्जिट
करके टाइम में कुछ एरर ए जाता है यहां पर
एरर आने के बाद में वो क्या करेंगे वैसे
तुम छोड़ो तुम तो पागल हो तुम अपने जो
पहले ब्लॉक हो जाएगा वो जान के बाद में
यहां पर तो फिर लिखा हुआ रहेगा ना उसे चीज
को फिर वो यहां पे एग्जीक्यूट करेगा
सिंपल
ट्री और एक्सेप्ट इसके साथ में मतलब वैसे
ये कर की और होते हैं लेकिन
ट्री राहत है की जैसे ही प्रोग्राम होगा
वैसे ही अपना यह
वाला जो ब्लॉक है वह एग्जीक्यूट होगा
एक्सेप्ट पहले ब्लॉक में जाएगा
ब्लॉक हो जाता है जैसे मां लो की अगर इसके
अंदर जैसे
मतलब एक्स = 0 कर देता हूं अगर ये वाला
अपना ब्लॉग एग्जीक्यूट हो जाता है ट्राई
वाला ब्लॉक एग्जीक्यूट होता है अपना तो
यहां पर
ये फिर ल से एग्जीक्यूट होगा
तो यह ट्राई के साथ साथ
ऐसा राहत है
अपना फाइनली
फाइनेंस
तुम जो
कम
नहीं करेगा
[हंसी]
यह भाई अपने दिल में चलते हैं
तो यह ऐसा अपना एक्सेप्शन के साथ में राहत
है तो इसके एक अपन रियल लाइफ सिनेरियो
देखते हैं
कैसा राहत है
वहां पर अगर मां लो मैं देखा हूं
ये मैं अगर रीड मोड के अंदर खोलना हूं ठीक
है ना फिर अपना प्रिंट करता हूं अपना
यहां पर ए गया
इंटर फाइल नाम और लोकेशन
देखो जो अपने यहां पर एरर ए रहा था वो भी
एरर अपना नहीं आया है
सीधा समथिंग वेट रंग लिख कर ए गए अब देखो
समथिंग वेट रंग तो क्या रंग हुआ है अगर
अपन को वो भी दिखाने का है ये पूरा एरर
अपना फाइल लोकेशन ये पूरा एरर ना दिखा के
ओनली इतना सा अगर अपन को दिखाने का है तो
उसके लिए अपन क्या लिखेंगे अपुन यहां पर
लिखेंगे
यहां पर वेबसाइट
क्या करेगा
जल्दी बताओ
मैंने
तो तीन बार बताया है
ओके ठीक है
मैसेज के अंदर आएगी भाई अपने कुछ गलती कर
दी है यह अपना पैटर्न का पीएफ फाइल अलग की
लाइन है जो यहां पर आई है वह भी आप देख
रहे हो
इससे क्या होगा ना प्रोग्राम भी टर्मिनेट
नहीं होगा
डेवलपमेंट
को सामने दिखता है तो डेवलपमेंट लोग को तो
पता ही है ना यार कहना क्या चाहता है तो
जब यूजर यह एरर कॉपी करके अपना
दिखाएगा मैं देखो अगर ये भी आगे लिख देता
हूं की
एरर और सेंड थिस तो योर
फाइनल डायरेक्टर
नहीं जाऊंगा प्रिंट
फाइल का नाम या लोकेशन गलत है
तो यह वाला ब्लॉग
तो उसके लिए है अगर आपको विश्वास नहीं है
तो फिर यहां पर मैं इस वाली लाइन में
कमेंट कर देता हूं ताकि यहां पर कोई
वेरिएबल नहीं आया रहेगा तो अलग नाम
दिखाएगा तो यहां पर मैं राहत हूं
अगर अपन को पता है की यार ये वाला ए सकता
है तो मैंने का नाम लिख दिया
कैसे पता चलेगा
ठीक है ना
तो वहां के बड़े में पता ग जाएगा
[हंसी]
यार यूजर इस नोट डिफाइंड करके बताइए बट या
ये जो लिखा हुआ है ना की यार 9 डायरेक्टरी
हार्दिक न्यूरोटिक की तो ये तो यार कोई
नॉर्मल सी यूजर भी समझ सकते हैं यार ये
कोई फाइल डायरेक्टर नहीं होगी इस चक्कर
में हल्का सा भी उसने अगर कंप्यूटर को ऑन
भी किया है तो समझ जाएगा
ठीक
है
ट्रैक क्षेत्र के बड़े में
पूरा कॉन्सेप्ट
के बड़े में बात करो
हर्ष भाई
क्या होता है की
डेवलप
होता है
जैसे अगर मैं यहां पर
ठीक है तो यह हर और के नाम होते हैं वह
नाम
लिख दो यहां पे आपने कॉपी किया है तो जब
भी ओनली यही वाला जो एरर आएगा ना मतलब तो
ये कम करता हूं
जो अपने यहां लिखा होगा जैसे एक्सेप्ट
देगा
फेल का नाम और लोकेशन गलत है
[हंसी]
यहां से जो भी चीज आई रहेगी
यह एरर तो एरर में जाके से हो जाएगा फिर
अपन जब चाहें तो उसे यारा तो को प्रिंट
करवा सकते हैं
ठीक है एक बार मैं इसको करके दिखता हूं
जैसे नॉर्मली अगर मैं यहां पर मैं रन करता
हूं यहां पर फाइल का नियम गलत देता हूं
अपना
फाइल और डायरेक्टर
कोई भी फाइल मौजूद नहीं है
तो उसने यह एरर दिया अपने को अब अपने को
हैंडल करना है
ब्लॉक लगा दूंगा
और अच्छे से अपनी तरीके से लिखना है तो इस
लिखने
जब भी यह रहा है तो आप प्रिंट करो की फाइल
का नाम या लोकेशन गलत है
कमेंट कर देता हूं
मैंने शुरू कर दिया यहां पर अभी कमेंट तो
मैं जब उसको से करूंगा तो देखो यहां पर ए
रहा है
बाद में तो क्या मतलब इस चीज को डिटेल अगर
वो लोग तो उसके बड़े में बताएंगे
वेरिएबल
ही नहीं है
तो बता दो
हां क्या भैया
सही बात है
बिल्कुल
यहां पर
दिखे जाएगा
वेबसाइट पर ए जाएंगे
क्लिक करूंगा क्लिक फाइल डाउनलोड
हो रही है
ठीक है
इंस्टॉल कर लो मेरा पहले से इंस्टॉल
थिंकिंग करना चाहिए उसको ठीक है
इंस्टॉलेशन कंप्लीट हो जाएगा तो
वेलकम
इनेबल कर देना अब इनेबल करने के बाद में
ना एक छोटा सा ट्रिक बता देता हूं की यहां
पे एक ब्लैक बॉक्स रहेगा
तो ठीक है ये ब्लैक बॉक्स है ना इसको भी
ना इंस्टॉल कर लेना इंस्टॉल जो भी आएगा वो
कर लेना होगा से बताता हूं अगर मैं मां लो
की यहां पे एक न्यू फाइल बनाता हूं अपना
लैंग्वेज है यहां पे सिलेक्ट करके ये मुझे
पाइथन का बनाने का पाइथन का फाइल बनाने का
है मुझे तो मां लो मुझे ना कुछ भी अगर
चाहिए जैसे तो मैंने कमेंट बनाऊंगा यहां
पर कलर बनाने के लिए देखूंगा
ठीक है
प्रोग्राम
है
सीधा यहां पे खुला जाएगा हैशटैग कमेंट के
लिए और जो लिखना है लिख दो फिर क्वेश्चन
मार्क लगाते ही है फ्रंट खुला जाएगा और जो
आपको कोड चाहिए ना वो कोड है सीधा करके ए
गया यहां पे कॉपी करके अपने प्रोग्राम के
अंदर एकदम से लेकर ब्लैक बॉक्स बहुत
बढ़िया यही चाट है जो अपने प्रोग्राम के
लिए
कम में ए सकता है
करवाना चाहूंगा जब भी आपको दिक्कत है मतलब
अगर आप कुछ कोडिंग वेडिंग भी कर रहे हो तो
ब्लैक बॉक्स जो है ना वो आपको अपने आप आगे
के जो कोड हो सकता है वो सजेस्ट कर देगा
फिर आप टायर दबाओगे तो वो कोड वहां पे
लिखा हो जाएगा या फिर प्रॉन्प्ट अगर आपको
चाहिए क्या आपने कुछ हैंडल कर दो तो ये ना
वो प्रिंट के बाद में एरर भी लिखने चले
जाएंगे अगर अभी अलर्ट लिखोगे तो अच्छा
अच्छा लगेगा तब उसे करते होंगे ना ब्लैक
बॉक्स को तो मजा आएगा जिन लोगों को किस
चीज के बड़े में नहीं पता था वो प्लीज आज
ये चाट में लिख देना या जैसा पसंद है जैसे
ठीक है थोड़ा हेल्प मिलता है
बता दो मुझे तो आज के लिए इतना ही और साथ
के अंदर में ही कहना चाहूंगा की थोड़े से
और प्रोग्राम टेस्ट करो
अपना फंक्शंस के बड़े में और थोड़ा दीप जो
ठीक है और भी चीज है इसके अंदर जो आपको
करनी चाहिए
अपना ये फंक्शंस के बड़े में
यहां पर आने के बाद
हमारे पेज पर आना यहां पर पोस्ट पर आना
यह दे फाइव का पोस्ट ए रखा है ठीक है वैसे
यह भी दे सिक्स कभी पोस्ट ए जाएगा तो उसे
पोस्ट से कमेंट में जाकर आप जो भी
एक्स्ट्रा सीखे हो अपना यह फंक्शंस के
बड़े में वह यहां पर कमेंट में दाल देना
या फिर आपने जो भी टेस्टिंग कोड वगैरा कर
रहे हैं वह कमेंट में दाल देना ताकि पता ग
जाएगा की हां भाई आपने क्या एक्स्ट्रा
पड़ा है आखिरी कमेंट पढ़ के बाकी लोगों को
भी एक्शन नॉलेज मिलेगा जिन लोगों ने अपना
फंक्शंस के बड़े में पड़ा है तो और अगर और
दीप में अगर लिखने हैं तो और उन लोग को
अच्छे से समझ में ए जाएगा तो दूसरों के
लिए बढ़िया है मेरे को भी समझ में ए जाएगा
अगर मेरा भी राहत है तो
ठीक है सो थैंक यू
अगर आपको कुछ फीडबैक है या फिर कुछ भी है
ऐसा तो आप लोग प्लीज कमेंट में लिख दो और
अभी थोड़ा सा अभी कम करता है अपने पास अभी
टाइम है नो मिनट का तो प्लीज थोड़ा डिस्कस
कर ले की कल प्रोजेक्ट बनाया है अगर आप
लोग के पास टाइम हो तो कोई भी टेलीग्राम
पे नहीं लिख के दे रहा है मुझे टैग करके
जिन लोगों को मुझे टैग करना है वो प्लीज
मुझे टैग कर सकते हो यहां पर
स्कोर मेरा टेलीग्राम का वो है
टैग कर देना ग्रुप के अंदर जो डिफरेंस है
कोई हैकिंग टूल से प्रोजेक्ट बनाइएगा कोई
भाई यह हैकिंग के टूल्स लाखों करोड़ है
कौन सा बना है कौन सा इंडिया बना है
यह चीज ही पूछ रहा हूं मैं तो दोस्तों
बहुत बन सकते हैं बहुत बना भी सकते हैं
कौन सा करना है मैं यही पूछ रहा हूं
खुद का जो छोटे रेलवे कॉन्सेप्ट
का बना सकते हैं
इंस्टाग्राम लॉगिन पेज मुझे लगता है पैठण
का कम है कोई लॉगिन कोई डिजाइन करना है
टेंशन नहीं करो पैसे निकालने में खत्म
नहीं होता है पाइथन के आगे और भी कोर्स
वगैरा और भी वीडियो वगैरा आने वाले हैं जो
कॉन्सेप्ट्स को और भी दीप में लेकर जाएंगे
और साथ में अपना कुछ प्रोजेक्ट्स भी लाइव
आके यहां पर करेंगे
तो अगर आप लोगों को सेशन र गया करते हैं
तो वो भी आजा पर नाइस करें जा सकते हैं
यह सब कुछ डिपेंड करता है की आप लोग कितना
इस चीज को इंटरएक्टिव बनाते हो और कितना
आप सपोर्ट करते हो
तो उसे पर सब कुछ डिपेंड रहेगा
ऑप्शन रहेगा
टेलीग्राम के जो भी जो भी रहेगा मुझे
ग्रुप में टाइप करो ग्रुप में ही रिप्लाई
आएंगे
जल्दी बताओ यार कल करने का है की नहीं
प्रोजेक्ट सर्किल का j7 छोड़ देते हैं अगर
कोई तक नहीं करने का है तो
विवर्स
इनके बड़े में बहुत ही स्लो नॉलेज है मैं
कर दूंगा मोदी की बात नहीं है उतना उतना
ऊपर से बड़ा कर लेकिन सॉकेट वगैरा सब में
नहीं आएगी तो फिर शायद कुछ ना हो पे
ग ये थोड़ा सा अच्छा लगा मुझे
अरे मैं चाहता हूं आप लोग को सजेशन हो आप
लोग की चौकिस इसका कुछ किया जाए
सबका अभी कम हो रहा हूं मैं वैसा कुछ
चाहता हूं इसके अंदर अभी तक प्रेजेंटेशन
भी नहीं बनाया है
सर सीधा
यह लोग
अभी की अगर अपन बनाएंगे तो फिर अभी अपना
जो विंडोज का डिफेंडर है वो इसको अलाउ
नहीं करेगा तो मतलब कर भी सकता है ना वो
कैसी है इनकी बात नहीं है मिल्क चलो
स्टाइल भी करवा सकते हैं
उनको
मैंने सोचा था क्वेश्चन पेपर मकर ही बनाया
था बट आप लोग तो हैकिंग से रिलेटेड चाहिए
था क्योंकि उसके अंदर अभी जो भी अपने
कॉन्सेप्ट पड़े हैं ना वो सारे कॉन्सेप्ट
उसके अंदर आते हैं थोड़ी बहुत चीज भी उसके
अंदर रहती है इसलिए मैं वही सोच रहा था
करने को
हां कल ही विजिट होगा अगर आप उधर के नाम
बता दो तो अगर आपको ये चाहिए हमें
प्रोजेक्ट नहीं करने का है तो वो भी बता
दो
इन क्वेश्चन डिस्क्रिप्शन
नोट किया है
कितने में खत्म नहीं होता है आपको तो
नेटवर्किंग के बड़े में जानना पड़ेगा ये
पूरा एक बढ़िया सा कोर्स लॉन्च कर देंगे
तो या फिर थोड़ा नेटवर्क पढ़ने के बाद में
फिर अपन कुछ अगर आपके बाद में कोर्स
नेटवर्किंग से रिलेटेड तो उसके बाद में
करेंगे तो ज्यादा बढ़िया रहेगा
चलो ठीक है सब लोग इस वीडियो के
डिस्क्रिप्शन के लिंक से टेलीग्राम का
चैनल जॉइन करो वहां पे पाल डालते हैं पाल
डालने के बाद में वहां पे जो रहेगा
क्लास होने के अपना 2 घंटा पहले मतलब
कितना चलो ठीक है कर बजे तक कल शाम 4:00
बजे तक कुछ पोलम के अंदर जितने भी मतलब
आएगा मेरे पास आ अपना जो भी रिजल्ट आएगा 4
बजे तक
क्योंकि 4:00 बजे मेरा कॉलेज खत्म होता है
4:00 बजे तक तो
फिर वही चीज कारी जाएगी
चलो फिर
मैं कोल्ड डालता हूं उसके हिसाब से अपन
देखते हैं